hey kitty kitties all right do me a
favor i want you to come see me live i'm
finally touring again all the tickets
are on savile countercomedy.com
many more dates will be added you guys
are always screaming at me the dates
they're going to keep being added but
these are the cities i'll be at uh if we
haven't done it yet right december yeah
this is airing thursday december 4th and
5th i'll be at the west palm beach
improv december 10th in boston the chevy
year theater december 11th at the
borgata kind of hometown thing atlantic
city new jersey there's only a few
tickets left for boston ac please get
those to come out december 26 dallas
december 27 san antonio december 28th
sugarland aka houston december 29th st
louis december 30th columbus and new
year's eve december 31st cincinnati all
those are with chris d and then my new
data just went up january 14th in des
moines january 15th in indianapolis
january 16th in cleveland january 29th
at foxwoods in connecticut we are adding
a show the first one is basically sold
out february 19th in washington dc
tysons virginia to be announced very
quickly uh
next week or this coming week i will be
announcing just so keep a heads up san
diego los angeles burlington vermont
detroit pittsburgh albany madison and
chicago all tickets savolcano comedy.com
uh more cities being announced i mean
it's a mouthful but i just i need you
guys to come out and see me because it's
been so long and we need to laugh and uh
this is casey jost everybody the earth
is
flat talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right hey taste buddies welcome to
the taste buds podcast i'm joe and i'm
sal
and this is t-a-s-d-e
buds welcome welcome welcome and we are
so thrilled to welcome i guess only our
second guest ever well
depending on when we air these okay yeah
right well one of our first guests ever
yeah uh and and technically in
chronological uh filming order our
second year yeah and sam of course uh
sam
from jim and sam is a radio personality
he's on wwe he's he's everywhere i look
all the time for years and years and
years uh he's a friend of ours and he
likes the show and we asked him if he'd
be on and he was so gracious to give us
his time on a work day yes gracious i've
made no secret that this is my favorite
podcast i told you i leave comments on
the homeless pimp i leave comments on
yours i vote in the polls
i did uh i did jim and sam last week to
promote the opening of the bar yeah joey
rose's which by the way
we're sitting and we're right
beautiful coming to fruition different
setting this week uh the next few
episodes will be shot in here yes um but
we're in here now uh preparing for our
friends and family event this evening
it's the the excitement is uh palpable
yeah this is because they're still
drilling and painting and deliveries are
coming in and signs are still going up
and we're just in the back trying to do
this but the energy to prepare for
tonight and it's exciting because
tonight's the very very first
functioning quarter night it's a solid
by
174 rivington street yeah 174 rivington
street joey rose's one zero zero two is
that zip in new york new york
uh can't miss it best signage in the biz
wednesday through sunday
baby all right and let me just say real
quick because we are this is really cool
the the place is twice the size that i
thought you got a whole vibe going on
here they were meticulous with the style
it is so cool it's old school social
club really fun it feels very new york
um i actually i love it love it love it
thank you there's so many nice touches
already and we're not even done up front
but the way you laid it out and the
design and all the cool little
tchotchkes and knickknacks yeah going on
the old school hip-hop vibe and all that
stuff thank you great stuff that would
be a good show by the way tchotchkes
versus knickknacks oh
that is good um
so so
so sam
i went to jim and sam thank you for the
kind words i went to sam
when you're ready you can as well
uh no i i went to jim and sam uh
recently to uh to hang out and to
we have an actual promote
on today yeah i know
sam yeah you're you're one of the last
remnants of the enemy of what we do
that's not how i meant it
i meant that we actually have a
professional in this field today whereas
we pretend i feel like podcasts have
actually become the enemy because it's
like you go like yeah i do a radio show
and it's like there's still
radio shows like people still do
radio
shows explain podcasts to people people
are all like what is radio yeah and now
you know it's like i do a radio show
they're like great it's like a it's like
a podcast so you know what's funny i
like radio better still i love i love
radio i love both i love i really love
shout outs
shout out to the bonfire shout out to
the bonfire shout out to uh taste buds
shout out to chrissy chaos
[Laughter]
no but it's funny speaking of bonfire so
i co-host bonfire usually when dan can't
be there
and um
i was doing it a couple weeks ago with
jay
and we were just in the middle of like
talking and i was like i'll be back dude
i go to the bathroom and he was like
we're on the air
i was like oh yeah i forgot i forgot
this isn't a podcast you have to like
yourself like be here yeah yeah yeah
broadcasting like live like yeah
shout out to the pimp as well who got
here and set up the setup set it up in
the back here and also by the way if i
just may again with pimps fit today
it is exciting yeah it looks great it is
exciting
i mean you you are combining all the
stuff that comes together and the sum is
the part what am i trying to say the sum
is the green is great
yeah it really is thank you thank you
man individually they're amazing they
come together to make you know this is
what happens when you walk by on the
street someone goes
they pull down and they look it was a
wild outfit right it was your boss and
everyone was screaming about taste buds
yeah just walk in the street yeah really
that's nice you got purple glasses a red
button-down collar a yellow into a a
rust sweater you got jeans that are five
different textures in ten different
colors and you got yellow high tops on
and it comes together and you look like
a fashionista george by the way yellow
george
forest right is those fours yeah oh the
fourth yeah yeah yeah my second favorite
jordan wild stuff wow
we could we could actually we could
actually uh co-op this entire episode
and just talk sneaky i mean we could go
once versus fours right now this is the
debate we're gonna
he doesn't we our sneaker would have
been great because we started doing um
you know you know we started doing like
not just food have pitched to you
several times and you always shoot it
down i always want to do converse versus
nike and you always say that's not a
good battle that is that makes no sense
it makes no sense whatsoever adverse
versus converse or wings the
conversation converse is like a it's
like a shoe tight not an entire brand
yeah you take it out
due to chuck taylor versus the jordan
one that's a great battle nobody's
eating that that's a
are they the real ones or replicas no i
mean no these aren't michael jordan
sneakers no but i mean are they the
remakes when they're the re-release
1985 either they fall apart yeah that's
what i'm saying
like three four years ago those
particular that particular shoe they do
og
shout out to angelo blando
i'm talking to him right now about that
new fragment travis guy it's so pricey
but now i especially love the love
that's the time
yeah now it's the time those are up to
700 now really yes sir look at me coming
correct yeah it's insane i know i really
wanted a pair of those actually fact
speaking of the man oh my god right
there
i was like
i don't know what to say
you can't get these you can't get them
well have you guys seen 100 700. why i
should you know
you probably bought them closer to
retail yeah yeah i got it when they came
out yeah yeah but even when they come
out now it's like it's like the cat's
out of the bag by the way
there's a there's a line around the
every sneaker store i walk by wondering
what happened literally as i was walking
to this podcast just now yes got him oh
the speakers have let me just
i got early access my alert came on i
texted joe derosa i said i'm on my way
and then
this popped up the gray elevens oh
very nice very nice
got him is a big deal got him doesn't
always happen it doesn't it really
doesn't no it really doesn't that's nice
that's a nice that's really nice
i don't have 11's they don't i can't
pull them off yeah i'm trying to pull
off the six even the six is tough the
conchords
yeah i know but concord 11. you could
pull off concord a little bit you think
so yeah
i got jared i got jay a pair for
christmas a couple years back those look
a little too marty mcfly to me a little
bit i mean the 11's are iconic they're
very they're very yeah and once you wear
them once you break them in a little bit
you'll realize like oh i should i saw
him on the shelf i thought it was too
futuristic but now that they're on my
feet it's me patent leather isn't patent
leather is involved it is and that's you
know most shoes you wouldn't yeah but
for an 11 you have to yeah yeah let's
announce by the way the battle of for
today real quick before we get two sides
another
uh another uh footnote in the history
books of taste buds we had yesterday the
first ever
independent three-way battle
stretch triple triple rule first time
with triple t
now here's a question false count
anywhere here's your question yes odq as
far as sam's
ranking in this battle is concerned it's
sort of irrelevant but where you and i
fall if i rank higher than you or vice
versa does that count as a win for us oh
i understand
so it's a ranked because usually triple
threat rules there's one win or two
losers i think sam goes into the stat
book as if he gets a winner a loss and i
feel like if you if if i win he's one
and oh yeah then we have to enter marion
too but ari was oh we do already
cheerios yeah yeah yeah but i mean you
guys take the l on it so like in your
record i think the first per oh that's
okay so this what we have to decide do
we decide are winning loss versus each
other or do we get two l's if he wins
because if you win i get the l and he
gets an l i think i think each person
gets one letter i think because it's a
triple threat it's not too hard damn it
and i feel like you're going to win with
your [ __ ] pick again i don't think
i'm going to win i think batman right
there is going to win you shouldn't
nobody knows who's got what yeah okay
hold on i'm definitely going to lose i
feel like i should
well on this one here's the thing on
this one yeah
i i feel like there's one winner and if
sam wins we take two l's that's what i
feel all right it's a wash anyhow and
then if one of us wins you get the w all
right let's do it so if you win we take
the else yeah it's a three-way soda
battle for best soda and then yeah
three-way shell better best solder which
i appreciate you guys doing because i
know you you guys haven't don't really
do sodas that much but i
i love sewing so your pick is
all-time favorite soda in the battle dr
pepper without thinking
so i and and although
although i agree i think the diet dr
pepper is my fave i did not want to come
that would have been unique though but i
didn't want to come with diet dr pepper
and i came with something i think is a
force of its own and i also love nearly
just as much and i'm going to take a w
root beer okay important that it's a w
root correct dads not mugs bart barks
mug yeah yeah right yeah
yeah no that's the right and uh i'm
going oh we don't have a i was going to
say what does a w stand for can you pull
that up
yeah i know i don't want to think about
it just yet yeah off the phone
and i'm going with my all-time favorite
soda since childhood cherry coke i mean
it's just a grand slam soda i like the
cherry coke pick on your end because a
lot of people think that dr pepper is an
equivalent to a cherry cola and it isn't
those people don't know what they're
talking about they're idiots cherry coke
is based with one flavor cherry cherry
and cola
i'll let you
wax poetic about the flavors i'll tell
you this cherry coke there's vanilla in
there cherry coke has hung on
it is like you know they've come up with
flavored pepsis and other flavored cokes
and would you take them really hang on
too bad yeah but come
on when they launched cherry when they
launched the new coke zero cherry coke
zero was right next to it cherry coke
zeroes in all time cherry coke has
become i would say cherry coke has paved
the way for cherry sodas more than
cherry pepsi i don't even think it has a
ring to it no offense but you don't say
i'll take a cherry pi cherry coke is a
thing wild cherry pepsi was huge in the
90s i love a wild wild cherry peppers it
was big but that was when there was
paint splashing
sherry in a wild cherry
it grows in the pepperoni
well look look here's something that
simpson hughes you're a wild cherry
that's like a no fresh cherry a wild
chip but what is a wild because i always
like wild i like cherry i think it's
wild hoffmann a
a cherry is grown with purple oh black
cherry
black cherry is the thing i like the
most that's what it sounds like but
that's not a cola that's its own soda
yeah yeah
black cherry's fine but i do not like a
black cherry probably my number sherry
three
okay but again you're talking about a
black cherry soda versus a cherry cola
right there's no cola in the black
cherries
correct and we also we are sticking with
brands today here yeah it's important
it's important
yeah we had to narrow it down otherwise
i could have drifted i should have just
called shasta original
a lot of people also think that dr
pepper is like either a coke product or
a pepsi product not true oh it's not no
in fact
people think that but it's not true it's
not true is it a product
it's its own there's another third
entity get out
is it rc owns it no i don't think it's
rc it wouldn't associate with rc uh you
know it wouldn't it wouldn't lower
itself i think you might
look it up
that's what i'm saying about shasta
remember shasta first i remember it was
like 11 cents a can actually yeah and
you drank it you like
remember president's choice did you
always have that where you lived no that
was my choice was the generic soda where
i lived and my dad would buy it and it
tasted like [ __ ] and then i would say
why can't you just get coke and you'd go
it's the same thing you're paying more
for the dumb label yes and it was nice
was pretty good my grandparents got rc
when i was younger she was in
in rotation
very recently shea stadium
yeah really rc was the mets cola [ __ ] rc
cola got the the city field account the
shade
city field but i know it had shed you
could still find rc up until a little
while ago you can if you look hard
enough i recently found a 20-ounce
bottle of rc cola and got so excited i
bought two on the spot
how'd it taste
i mean it was it was as good as a
throwback it's not i'm not gonna sit
there and go like oh this is so much
better than coke or pepsi it's simply
not but it's a throwback to be like oh
yeah it's rc i i knew i was drinking
something different you ever go into one
of those like i see them in a lot of
towns we go to on the road but they'll
have like a it's a candy slash soda a
soda specific source you especially just
remind me get third
is a huge soda head
yeah he goes and gets like he goes to
those stores and tries all the like
hundreds of different types of i'm so
can i tell you can i tell you it's one
of the things i envy about a guy like
gethered and also about a guy like sam
guys that don't drink can do stuff like
that right get third doesn't take a
device that you they could have taken
you don't have room for another vice
babe i got it yeah
come on
out of my ear
you don't have room for another video
i'm gibson and lethal weapon one right
now
i mean that's brutal
i got it i mean but you really want to
jump
[Laughter]
but i mean a guy like gether can just go
and be like whenever i go to a city on
the road i go to rocket fizz and i get
every soda and candy i'm like yeah
we missed you buddy shut up chris
there's nothing better
than going to like a 7-11 or gas station
store in the middle of the country that
is a testing area where brands will will
send true potential flavors yeah yeah
you can get like uh like like before the
white chocolate eminem goes naturally
it'll be in this like mobile store
7-eleven so there are times where you
can go in like right now i love going
into a store where i can find the like
fountain flavored pepsis and like they
have oh they do that cream soda ah
yeah yeah or like uh he hates cream soda
he hates cream soda can you buy it i
hate cream soda it's like a dessert
wait before we get into that yeah cause
i'm gonna dip into that in my argument
let's start the battle you're right
let's kick it off we didn't we didn't do
the battle challenge okay oh okay all
right ready
oh wait [ __ ] this is three-way sam's
gotta enjoy
yeah yeah yeah yeah
my favorite podcast
oh that was what i was gonna say earlier
i kept getting sidetracked uh from
finishing the story i did jim and sam
and sam talked to me at length on the
air and so did jim but sam really talked
at length on to me on the air about
taste buds and how much he loves which
is so funny that's his favorite podcast
and i said i said them on the air i'm
like why don't you just come do one next
week with us
that's so cool i didn't want to talk
about taste buds because it's like i've
known joe forever so it's like i don't
want this to be like one of those like
interviews where it's like so you do
this podcast right here like it's like i
feel like i know joe better than that
but i feel so passionate about the
debates that you guys have i love this
yes no it's real you know it's kind of
so today we decided to go all out so
yeah a lot of it is thanks to those
clips
so can i can i do a can i tell him
something like a callback to when i was
on jim and sam real quick absolutely not
[Laughter]
so remember so the other thing we did on
jim and sam was you had me read the
email that i fired off to the company
where i was pissed all right so this is
a true story i i think i can't go in the
store anymore this happened to me since
then what happened
there's a store right around the corner
called lot less oh yeah i filmed that
yeah it's uh
and i was like this is like an odd job
like you need like spoons or something
like you run in there you get it right
so uh
i go in the other day i got to do
bennington
and i it was a zoom thing so i i forgot
my headphones so i'm like [ __ ] i need
like a headphone shoot [ __ ] you forgot
your recons yeah
yeah actually i did
so i'm like [ __ ] and i didn't have time
to go home to get them so i go into a
lot less i get like one of those six
dollar headsets sure it'll work fine
i come in here i open it it's broken
into like pieces right you've been six
dollars for a year yeah so i go back
they should be not broken yeah and i go
back and i i show them the broken thing
and i but i i
somehow lost the receipt i forgot like i
left it but you were just in there
three minutes later but did you go to
the same person yeah okay okay and the
lady at the register she's like oh yeah
no problem and she's trying to do the
return and then the gm comes out and the
gm goes
you have a receipt and i go no
and he goes where's your receipt without
your receipt i can't do anything i go
come on buddy i was in here three
minutes ago she remembers me
and she goes well i gave you a receipt
and i go no no i know
she turned on you yeah and i go i know i
gave you you gave me one i just i i
don't have i was just here and the guy
goes without a receipt i can't do
anything
and i go
what is going to happen
without the receipt
right by the way keep in mind
six dollars yes
i have a story like this that happened
with me with the latin invasion karaoke
the radio shack so i told her on hey
roll with the guy i go what it's going
to happen without the receipt the guy
points to a sign he goes store policy
you need a receipt and i i hold the box
in his face
and i go let me get this straight you
think i went home and made a lot less
sticker and put it on the box
to scam you out of six dollars and the
guy goes
can't do anything without the receipt
and i go really
merry
christmas you're a
dildo
everybody right dead silence
by the way it's not even that close to
christmas
well like middle of november
[Laughter]
[Music]
he stared at me and i go you heard it
and i swear to god he just turns to an
employee just goes
how are you doing today
[Applause]
i pay for the new headphones and as the
woman's ringing me up she's just under
her breath she goes i'm so sorry about
it
she's going like this
you take that receipt you walk out
you'll walk back in with the broken ones
you go i found my receipt
what are you doing you had a different
one
why would you guys repair because they
didn't have the ones i bought you bought
the last pair of pokemon
by the way this is why you've got a
problem because you're dealing with
somebody here that is complete he thinks
your rage is justified like you're
sitting there going like you got um
instead of being like joe it's six
dollars
no no that's a big principle thing for
me but i would have loved i would pay
money i would pay actually he called him
a dildo
i know but the guy was being a dildo
he was i would pay real cash to have
been there for that
real cash
oh my god
wait i love the fact that he goes merry
christmas you dildo
and then
strolls back
to the headphones and just stops looking
like start shopping again
i had the exchange i had the exchange
fair oh my god but it was it was uh
it remember the brand of one the brand
that's broken let's talk to them
straight in the cam
i don't it was you know who knows that
you know fun phones or whatever you know
they have like all generic brands you
heard what i said you heard what the
[ __ ] you heard what i said
and then she still apologized after her
explosion but she was just walking she
wasn't apologizing she was afraid yeah
it could be you scared her i was walking
back see here from there with the
headphones i was laughing the entire
walk home i was like this is so funny
and so crazy six dollars is worth the
memory yeah and you were the first guy i
thought of because i love it you were
the first guy i thought because because
you because you were making fun of me on
the show for sending the email that said
for being too angry yeah when the lady
said be patient for your order and i
said funny i didn't tell you to be
patient when i gave you my money
[Laughter]
you know what the best part about the
fact you have this beautiful
establishment is now you are going to
have to be in customer service you're
going to have to deal with darosa's
coverage
and you're going to have to be cool
because they're going to put the
customer yes the hunter becomes the
it's babble time babies uh learning a
new language can be feel intimidating uh
we all know that every time the first
time i try to learn french i [ __ ] myself
uh when i first
thanks to babel though which is the
number one selling language learning app
the whole process is totally fun they
have these 15-minute lessons you could
do it on your phone on an app on the go
it's fast and easy we talk about this
all the time you could pick it up if
you're trying to learn a hobby if you're
trying to impress a gal or a guy or
whoever uh if you're trying to talk to
your grandparents because they came off
the boat um all that stuff they have
over uh it was created by a hundred
language experts which is very cool they
use
other places use artificial intelligence
i didn't know that but now we know for
their lesson plans not babble real folks
real language experts it's different
you'll see as soon as you start using it
the teaching method is scientifically
proven to be effective and i know that
to be true because it's not like when i
used to learn in high school i actually
pick stuff up here they have 14
different languages and they have a
speech recognition technology that helps
improve your pronunciation and accent
right now when you purchase three months
of babble uh of a babel subscription you
get three months free that's not that's
pretty good that's six months for the
price of three just go to babel.com of
course use the promo code tastebuds so
that's b a b b e l dot com code taste
buds babble we love you language for
life oh boy hello who is it hello who's
this is it hellofresh it's been a minute
and it's great to have you back right
hello fresh you get fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store
and count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable that's
why it's america's number one meal kit
look if you guys haven't tried
hellofresh off of the heels of this show
yet i don't know what to tell you it is
a game changer i use it all the time i
do not cook it is fun and i feel like
i'm a better person than i actually am
because it's fun to cook especially if
you and if you know how to cook then
you're a step ahead and you'll get new
recipes they offer 50 manual market
items to choose from every single week
for vegetarian calorie smart gourmet
options plenty of variety there right so
hello fresh meals are also ready in 30
minutes or less so if you're a guy like
me who's a man about town or you're
coming home and you popped out five kids
and you're regretting it well that meal
is going to be ready in 30 minutes or
less plus with that quick and easy meals
those are 20 minute recipes if you need
that 10 minutes extra or low prep and
easy clean up options you get food on
the table quicker spend more time on
with the holiday if your loved ones
that's an easy one
so some of the recipes they have listen
to this because it's fancy uh balsamic
and fig beef tenderloin man i love fig
you like fake
pretty good i love fig pecan crusted
salmon i'm not even just saying this a
pecan whoo all day
make holiday meals feel special they do
feel like more seasonal meals uh or go
uh for a cozy comfort food choice like
chicken sausage and sweet potato soup
for a cold one tonight damn i'm getting
hungry uh so yeah guys go to
hellofresh.com taste buds one four and
use code tastebuds14
for up to 14 free meals and three
free
i ain't gonna tell you what it is you
gotta go there and check it out that is
enticing enough for me to check it out
so that's hellofresh.com
tastebuds14 and then use the code
tastebuds14 for up to 14 free meals and
three free gifts uh
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
i do i say i told the story on
bennington and i was like i got a lot of
karma coming my way dude i got a lot of
oh i need you to text me the moment call
me on the phone the moment you get
called to dildo for the first time
[Laughter]
oh my god
i i i i actually never thought of it
you're gonna have to do yelp stuff
you're gonna have to deal with people
i don't want to think about it i don't
want to think about it i don't want to
think about it oh could you imagine him
seething as he tries to type back a pc
response
to you for your input i will not be
typing the response
all the taste buddies swarm the yelp
let's help the help oh yeah that's how
yeah with good reviews good
please yeah some people think it's funny
to like leave a half a star that's not
funny because they think it's like
they're in their fans and they think
it's like funny like they're so please
don't do that that's not funny
[Music]
and please come enjoy it and then leave
a real review you know come enjoy
um joy
yeah i won't even get into but i bought
a latin invasion karaoke cd
but this is when latin invasion was the
thing
right what was oh like ricky martin and
all that stuff okay yeah all that they
invaded right and you knew all the words
yeah
so you just need the karaoke yeah and
then what pim do you remember the story
of why why i remember it went down in a
radio shack yeah so i brought it home
and i i think i i think i
i don't know i know what happened this
is what happened i brought it home and i
i uh i opened it i think
something like something like this
someone else got me it yeah as a gift
i mean i guess i was really into the
latin invasion at the time it was like
2003. wait let me just who was it
you're better than me go back and really
search yourself in 2003. we were all
invaded by the latins
backtrack for one second
question i am latino did you have
yeah no i know but did you have a did
you have like a home karaoke machine
indeed i did joe indeed i did okay okay
okay so no so you know what a lot of
people did back then that was like a big
thing i think it was either for me or i
did i bought my grandparents a karaoke
machine
and i got they were also into the latin
invasion they were so yeah my
grandmother you couldn't afford it
couldn't avoid it
so i think what happened was i bought
them it and then someone else got them
it and i had opened it already and they
kept the other one and i tried to return
the other one and i had the receipt and
by the way to this day i
pulled it out on hey babe i have the
latin invasion cd and the original
receipt
you talked in 2003 18 years ago you
talked about whatever it was
you talked about i think it was 23 you
talk about losing your receipt walking
out of the store 18 years later i'm
holding on to this receipt for principal
i walked in i said hey
i said i would like to uh to return this
thing right and there was a guy in there
i'll tell the story real quick i know we
gotta get going right yeah yeah okay guy
in there and this is one of the guys
that played fast and loose with the
radio shack uh
uniform rules
[Laughter]
radio shack like collared but like a
like a button down with a radio shack on
it but he put in a leather vest over it
okay a black leather vest and he had on
those like rings that were like a snake
going into the skull's eyes yeah he was
almost like he wanted you to know like
yeah i work here but i am still cool
yeah yeah yeah yeah he had on the chat
like that he's married to a theater
professor yeah yeah
you know that like those like black
leather cheap jewelry with the cheap
stuff on it he had all that stuff on
like the chokers from earlier he the guy
definitely wanted to rock while he
worked sure
so sure a picture
big j working at radio it was like it
was like
like like a
like a maybe like he was also like not
exactly white but i don't remember what
his nationality was but it was like it
was like almost like a big j working
there okay yeah and it was during uh
this was christmas so it was during the
return period so the mall was a zoo
there was a line going out the front i
waited on that line i waited like 20 30
minutes to get to the line i get up i
said i'd like to return this
i put the receipt down and he goes um
i can't give you your money back and i
said why i got the receipt he goes it's
opened media
he goes you can go get a new latin
invasion cd okay and that's it and i
said well i i don't want another latin
invasion because i had already they had
already got the latin invasion cd why
was it open
i think that i cut it open and then like
to play it for them and then they opened
another one and i was like oh i'll just
bring mine back i wasn't thinking like i
couldn't right bring it back and he goes
he goes no i can't do that and i was
like what do you mean i have the receipt
and everything he goes no because
that's not the store policy i said well
it doesn't work
it doesn't work and and he goes well if
it doesn't work get another one and i
said no no no i think this brand of mtv
latin invasion cd probably is
incompatible right with the the the
karaoke thing i bought so it's not my
problem yeah and he goes yeah we cannot
do that it's mixed media he goes how do
i know you didn't go home
by the way there's 50 people in line
behind me yeah he goes how do i know you
didn't go home
burn the latin invasion cd oh rip it
he's got a great point and come back
it's a fair point i said
oh now you're taking his side
that's a fair point
no that's a fair point but i said to
yeah but just like you i said do you
think babe you babe you're talking
heyday of napster when this is happening
i said do you think i said it was 9.99 i
said it's principal i said i'm coming
back here to the return side it's 9.99
you think i
took my time drove to the mall bought
the cd drove home opened it ripped it
drove back and got 99 what about gas and
by the way it's the karaoke version yeah
it's not even the hits right it's not
even the hits it's not it's not even the
lyrics we're turning exactly i know all
right right so so i'm like so i was like
you think i'm doing this whole thing to
scam radio shack out of 9.99 plus tax
he's like i can't do nothing about it i
go what i want to talk to your manager
he goes you can't
i'm gonna go what do you mean i can't he
goes he's on the phone
i was like what i go what do you mean
he's on the phone he goes he's on the
phone with houston
yeah
it was all of houston
from who houston i go how do you know
you're not in the back he was because he
was on a call i said well what if he's
ought to call he goes all right he walks
from behind the counter in his [ __ ]
leather dress with all his jewels
he goes he pushes the [ __ ] they have
like that door he pushes the door i see
him and he's a window and he pushes the
door turns around pushes it comes back
out like a real dick like a real dildo
yeah
he walks right down and he's he's back
out i think it was for emphasis
he was prodding doors like they go into
at the supermarket he swung back
definitely didn't speak to anyone he was
yep he's on the phone with houston
that was it no oh he gets in front i
said i
will wait for him to get off the phone
with houston good for you sorry it might
be a half hour
i said i'll wait so i i pivot two to the
right and he starts helping people now
all the people saw this fight happen and
now he's like hi and he's being overly
nice to them
oh let me return like this guy's the
problem
he's being a real dick right dildo dildo
right and then finally i was like this
is you know this is ridiculous i go i
start appealing to people i go this cd
is broken don't return a broken cd they
won't take it back here at radio show by
the way the cd was not broken no it
wasn't broken
compatible yeah and i was like and i was
like taking digs at radio shack i was
like you know what yeah okay i was like
you guys specialize in
wires you know like
like why does anyone come in here it's
always for shady [ __ ] it's always like
oh i want to steal cable from my i don't
get this coax it's all [ __ ] right
right true so i'm going on and on
finally he goes you know what he grabs
the cd he goes from around the thing and
walks over to aisle one where all the
karaoke machines are pops open the
karaoke machine puts it and closes it
hits play and it's like damn stan
i forgot
the whole line is looking at us and
they're like oh man
oh my god and and he's just he's just
staring at me and then he hit stop and i
go
well it doesn't play on my machine
and then he goes back
and he goes back and i'm like i i
couldn't let it go so then i just he's
taking people i go back up there and i
just go
look man i go i'm not trying to scam got
a 9.99
the thing doesn't work the new one's not
gonna work i was like it's christmas i
was like and i just took a nice i go
just just take it back
[Music]
just just take it back you know and he
goes and then he puts his hand on he
goes
i can't take it back
and then and then oh and i went to push
it back and he put his hand on it we
both had our hands on i'm like come on
dude
what's the big deal man just do it he
goes i can't sir and i go why can't you
just do it he goes i can't
and he's like next and he's like have a
good day and who's really gonna do this
have a good day and i go come on he goes
i swear he said this i swear i think it
was part of his like being a dick he
went i said good day
[Laughter]
oh my god
willy wonka was working there and then i
picked up the cd and i was like you know
how the spice is going to [ __ ]
as i walked out he scrooge
scrooge says to his nephew yes
jesus two things there number one you
were right because they went out of
business yeah no surprises
[ __ ] but number two
shocking
that you both have similar stories i
think both of you are nuts however you
supported joe in his story joe did not
support you
hold on
hold on a second hold on a second hold
on a second the only reason i didn't
support him is because i've pulled this
move he rookied it up he rookied it up
let me tell you how many cds
and video game discs i've taken a sharp
rock to the back
and put a groove in it and then brought
it in and went
look at this man they came out of the
box like so you would rip them when you
got home no i wouldn't even rip it so i
don't want you destroying the city i
didn't like it i didn't want it anymore
so i go back i'd be sitting in the
parking lot at best buy i would take a
shark wait wait you got you go put it on
and listen to the the ten tracks in your
car right after you bought it no i would
but i would bring it home and listen to
it and then if i was like damn this
album sucks or this video game sucks i
played a level i don't like it whatever
but i'm out but wouldn't they tell you
to go get a new one here's what i would
do i would go in
again
in the parking lot take a sharp rock to
the disc put a groove in it go in
and my first line of defense was
i think this is the defective batch i
don't want to get a new another one and
then it's like this i simply don't trust
that if i get another one it won't right
so sometimes they would say okay fine
we'll give you your money or we'll give
you a store credit but not your money
back which was as good it was good for
credit cards
but then they would sometimes say they
have a groove i can give you another one
but that's it you say okay you get the
other one don't you finger crossed that
the cashier does not sometimes they
would do that
and then you leave and come back two
days later or send a friend in with the
receipt in the product two days later
and you get your money back yeah that's
the only reason i didn't support him the
way he went about it you could see his
scheme from a mile away so you're saying
that you're you're
insanity but but but you're a
professional about it it's a this is
it's a short current it's it's a
shortcut you can't [ __ ] a [ __ ]
amateur you think radio shack doesn't
know though
that's a story for another time when you
come back because that's i think it's
but i had this happen to me with the
nintendo wii
you tried to return a whole week at a
target and it was a hole to do right no
no i never heard this sure sure the
nintendo wii i haven't heard that yeah
but i tried to return it at target and
they called me out
i feel like this is actually the battle
are you serious yeah and i and i forgot
i didn't tell this on a baby no no no
it's just what time we have here we got
about 15. we're approaching 30 minutes
right now all right we got about 15 left
how long of a story is this
not that i don't want to hear it
we are covering some important grounds
we are but i mean i'm just wondering can
this just be enough about the soda
battle can you can we could be really
the soda battle could really be feverish
for 15. okay you know i think how are we
going to go i'm not trying to
listen to me i can tell the story i
could not tell the story what i would
like to hear about this toy story i want
to hear the story because here's my
here's my issue now
i
painted joe as somebody who is a very
very bad friend that is true and he came
back and said not a bad friend but
painted you as an amateur right very
true so i need to know maybe this wii
story gets sal out of that amateur
corner or maybe pins you in it okay okay
okay very good so i bought a wii
and i graphed by that i brought it
thank you so much i got it home i bought
it at target and i got it home and i was
playing it and i you know made my mies
and you know i
put in my thing and i set it all up and
i had it for a few months and the the
wii sports game that it came with never
worked in it from day one i'd put it in
it it would spin not register and pop
back out and i'm like what's going on so
i was like it's got to be the disc so i
took the disc to a friend's house i put
it in there it worked
so what is the discrepancy here i've
narrowed it down that something my
machine but machine was playing other
discs i couldn't figure it out it
bothered me forever because especially
those sports games with no barrier to
entry those are the ones you could play
with your nieces or your grandparents or
something to come over because it's just
going like that i couldn't throw on
something like final fantasy tell me
what this we can do let me show you and
that's what you think that's exactly
what you put on it's like
this yeah it's it's it's fun yeah that's
the party disc yes that's the part i was
hesitant to buy ones after that because
of the ptsd with this one not working i
didn't know what's going on right
finally it dawns on me
well you know what you should do
you should go put yours back in the box
i always save all the boxes i have the i
have my nintendo nes system 8-bit in its
original packaging and condition
i saw his sega genesis you have your
2003 receipt yeah for your latin
characters
genesis in the box one day in a closet
and i swear to god i thought he had just
purchased one on ebay
because it's in like perfect yes wow
yeah nintendo i have in the everything
in its original box i even have the nes
advantage the gun all that stuff because
you kept all the boxes from when you're
a kid in the boxes 1987 when i got that
with my confirmation money toys
[Music]
kidding me i'm a huge video game guys i
mean what's the point of having them so
display the box or you mean hook up the
system i would have shelves with all
these displayed on them dude with the
box yeah put another joker's bobble head
up on your shelf
i don't have any of them no yes you do
you're talking about the russian doll
thing you get the four joker's bobble
head it's the one russian doll thing i
opened up oh and then you have four
bobble heads i don't have four bobble
heads i swear to god
pimp back me up i don't have a joker's
bobblehead i'm sorry there's at least a
bobblehead of you wow
don't look like that's not the joker
bobblehead i have a joker's bottle
that's not enough the bible those bubble
heads are custom from friends that gave
me gifts of myself i'll make a better
i'll take a better job you might take a
better shot but
you know the replica of the seinfeld
setup he's got a replica of the seinfeld
set
just
put a pin in it for next time pimp fans
suggest for me and sal to battle
seinfeld versus curb yeah yeah we're
going to love that oh that's great what
would you take
i could take either but i'll take curb
because i know you you i could take you
there
sophie's choice i don't know if i could
do it i love it though i'll tell you we
could do that you've got a toy christmas
movie oh yeah
oh it's appropriate we're rolling up on
christmas 100 you can do it three ways
whatever you like what happened with
this
what happened with this okay so mike let
me go back i said what i'll do is i'll
package mine back up
and i'll know how to do it because you
have everything in the box i have
everything in the box i'll go i'll buy a
new wii okay and so i did this so i take
everything back and i keep the wii in my
car of mine and i walk in and i go and i
buy a brand new wii and i go to the
camera i buy the wii and i walk out to
my car with the receipt with the receipt
and the new wii
i get in my car i open up both boxes and
i just swap the main system
i i take the uh the new wii
and i put my old wii just the main in
the new box
this is professional this is great okay
everything i don't touch
the controllers very good one in the
other one and i walk back in five
minutes later
okay now listen to this yarn
i walked up to the to the return and i
go hey
i was just in here right i said here's
the receipt i said i just bought this
for christmas for my niece as i got to
the car my my sister texted me said they
got her a wee ah i don't need it right
so i handed it and i'm like oh this is
amazing i'm finally gonna do this and
the guy goes oh yeah all right and then
he goes and he looks and there's a
serial number
on the box that should match the serial
number on the actual item that matches
the serial number on the receipt so he
opens the box looks at the serial number
looks at the serial number box picks up
the system looks at the serial number
says i can't take this back it's a
different serial number when he opens
the box do you panic [ __ ] myself
yeah [ __ ] piss bomb same time wow
that's disgusting i know yeah so i'm
like oh what are you doing he goes i
can't take this this doesn't match the
thing i go uh i i i i i look like i just
got off the boat from from ellis island
i was like
i was like i don't want to see what he's
saying he goes it doesn't match the
thing and i go what does that have to do
with me because because this isn't what
should have come with this you're acting
like it's some kind of company error
like okay i go but i was in here three
minutes ago i have the receipt i just
walked out i go what does that have to
do with me and he goes because
i don't know what you did with that and
i go what i did with it i go this is
absurd yeah he goes because
what you just did people are doing and
that's why we're checking the serial
numbers so he goes i'm sorry i can't do
it on the bat i go this is unacceptable
this item is freaking four hundred
dollars i said there's no way in hell i
go i just explained to you what happened
let me speak to your manager he goes and
gets a manager man it comes out after a
little bit of back and forth to the same
kind of thing i start to get loud and i
go this is unacceptable i go this is
outrageous i go how do you know
someone didn't do this before me you
didn't check it and now i'm getting
screwed because the person that did it
before me i'm i'm innocent here
i'm a victim right were you innocent i
was not okay okay yeah but i i really
you know and so i've heard it all before
i start getting loud
but see okay so this is what's so crazy
for people that work in stores right
because something that's getting loud
and principled like you said you were
you'd go like well there's no way this
guy is losing his mind over a lie right
but you were i was but can i just
disagree i think the exact opposite i
think a guy starts getting loud that's a
tell me no because if it was true
no no no if i was if it was true i would
have got even more intense let me see
can i just can we hearken back to the
original thing which is we should i did
get served a broken wii originally so
really in my heart of hearts
is just why did you wait so long why
didn't you just take those
14 day window yet it didn't occur to me
it didn't occur
went off all right i'm like i can't
believe this come on i'm in here all the
time i was like look up my um
i was like take my card look at how much
i buy because i used to be a target king
i used to go in like whoa i used to say
i didn't go in talking about spending
3-400
you thought that the card could almost
serve as a character witness yeah yeah a
good person like all receipts i'm in
here all the time i can't believe you
received this level of scrutiny at a
target too so the guy that's why
the manager succumbs
he says all right
fine
he refunds my credit card takes takes it
back
goes puts it back
i was like oh my god i did it so i go
home
i get home i put the wee in
i put in the the thing it works i'm like
oh my god [ __ ] i i did it right
it's a brand new box so it's like set up
do we so i go all right i hit set up and
i go in to start putting in my credit
card information my and make the and i
go oh dear god
i didn't wipe my old machine
it's got every single it's got my name
as a me in it it's got all my credit
card information it has me's i made that
in this day and age might be problematic
like
and i said the next person who buys that
is going to be able to just buy any game
they want with all my credit card
information know who it is
and i was like i can't believe this i i
had all my sign-in information and so i
had to go back no yes i went back
and
my cue came with me and we went back and
we went in and i went through i took the
old boxes serial number and i went
through every single one they had and i
found the i opened the one with my fake
one in it on the shelf on the shelf he
put it back on the shelf so i found the
box for my receipt serial number so i
knew that mine was in that old box is
that box and i i
saw that it was true
and then uh and i i took my i think i i
had to i i bought the new one
that's what i did i bought that one
again
because you couldn't go in through they
scanned it i went out went into no no no
took mine back put mine in my box put
the real one that went with that one
back back in and walked in and returned
it with no issue because it was actually
the real one like a week later with a
different person oh my god dude can you
believe that i mean jesus christ i'm
going to tell you this
joe's right this is amateur hour
this is you are not
equipped for this game like you you
understand when i when they asked me to
make a me
it was like the end of usual suspects
when i was realized that kaiser so i
dropped my mug on the floor in slow
motion i was like oh my god all my
information is in the other one
i have the broken wing
wow you can't play that sports game
can't play it to this day see
now
i gotta
now i want to tell another scam story
this is the episode i mean what do you
mean this is the episode we gotta give
him a battle we put out a poll scams
no i know why don't we just move this
this battle to joe list and and we have
to do a battle we can't force joe list
to battle look i'm already like thinking
forward like can i tell you with this
scam that's going on right now yeah see
the longer i keep this going i think i
got a second app
oh
so this is where i'm
wow you know this is where what i'm
working i'm like he let's keep going
with the scams like classic sam roberts
on time it's still not for 21 minutes
then we have an about a 30 minute buffer
for an hour episode before jay comes so
why don't you
think about how long this story is and
if i say do it wrong at all so then so
then we'll go hard in the paint for 15
minutes on the sodas
we're not going to okay let's hear about
this game we're here we're in where
you can't swim again
this is the portrait of a man pulling
off a scam beautifully you ready yeah
yeah yeah keeps keeps keep skips keeps
guys
we're back on it with keeps here okay
uh two out of three men these are some
facts before i get into this two out of
three men experience some form of hair
loss by the time they're 35 more than 50
million men million men in the us suffer
from male pattern baldness and there are
only two fda approved medications that
can actually prevent hair loss keeps has
them both uh i have a thick
lush
illustrious mane but i uh got some keep
samples and i gave them to my loving
friend james murray who has had a
follicle challenged
head for a while he's been using him and
he
gives me a thumbs up on the keeps
products um they also offer simple
stress free weed
jesus lord
free weed wait not wheat weeds i'm not
talking about drugs i'm talking about
bushes
anyway excuse my slip up so here's how
you do it convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications are
delivered straight to your door every
three months so
you talk to the doctor on the on the
online on your on your notebook on your
desktop and then you get the stuff to
your door you don't have to leave your
home
it's local it's ten dollars a month they
start it that treatments are ten bucks
and they offer generic versions so it's
cheap uh discrete packaging so you don't
have to worry about
the neighborhood talking about you and
proven results that's true they have
more five star reviews than any
competitor and
what they say is prevention is key okay
so keep what you have
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act right away why not
right in time for the holiday if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keps.com
taste buds to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's keps.com
tastebuds to get first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash taste buds babe
you catch more flies with honey than
vinegar that's an old saying and you
save more money with honey than not
using honey when you're shopping online
that's my saying
i have honey on all my browsers i really
do i've been doing all my online
christmas shopping right now and i tell
you right now it's i always freak out
when it says apply promo code and i go
searching the internet and all these
fake sites come up and i keep trying
them and they say that code doesn't work
there's a button on the top of your
browser at checkout you touch it it's
the honey button it populates everything
i save money all the time today's
episode sponsored by honey of course we
all shop online we've seen that promo
code field taunt us to check out thanks
to honey manually searching is a thing
of the past that's what i just said
based on personal experience honey is
the free browser extension it's free
guys it scours the internet for the
promo codes and it applies the best ones
to your cart uh they work with over 30
000 online stores so unless there's some
weird store that we never heard of it's
probably gonna work and they range from
tech sites that have gaming products to
fashion brands even food delivery sites
so imagine you're shopping at one of
your favorite sites you check out the
honey button drops down all you do is is
click apply coupons that's true i used
it last night wait a few seconds they'll
search and it'll populate if he finds a
working coupon the prices drop right
there uh i've saved money so far on
everything from flowers to headphones to
bathing suit actually how much did you
save i don't i mean how much do you save
how much did i save the most i've ever
saved on one checkout right now i think
has been 60 bucks that is significant to
me i don't know that's a lot of money
honey has saved it's over 17 million
members over 2 billion in savings look
out branson
if you don't already have honey you can
be straight up missing out on free
savings and it's free it's literally
free and it installs in a few seconds
and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast get honey for free
dot
at
slash taste buds that's join honey dot
com slash taste buds
i used to do this thing where i liked i
liked different fast food items from
different places and i wanted to ascen
my friend jason told me this taught me
this and i wanted to assemble
my own fast food meals
without having to pay
so for instance what do you mean like
free i'll tell you what i mean for
instance wendy's i wanted the fries
mcdonald's i wanted the quarter pounder
those items are all available yeah but
i'm saying like i liked i liked like the
mcdonald's fries you wish your meal
could come with a b a bespoke meal with
a burger from your burger of choice to
fry from your product you get the burger
from wendy's
fries from mcdonald's i wanted to get
the chicken sandwich from burger king
okay right
so i would go to all three
and i would lie
i mean the lie part because you couldn't
go and say try to get a whole meal that
was the other thing too you had to yeah
that was really the basis of the sk of
the grift was that if you went to
mcdonald's and said
i ordered from here a little while ago
and an entire value meal was missing
they smell a rat right but if you go to
mcdonald's you go hey guys i was sort of
drive through a couple hours ago or an
hour ago whatever it was you forgot my
large fries they would go oh sorry about
that pull around and they would just
give you the fries wow
you don't have to show a receipt it was
right when they started doing receipts
so
the one time
they weren't doing receipts forever at
mcdonald's they wouldn't the fast food
drives they would not do you got to
remember there was a time when they
weren't taking credit cards dude i'm
talking 2 000. all right
this is new millennium yeah
we don't know
98.99 like it was a different game i
feel like i've gotten a receipt for my
food since the day i was born i think so
no they they're faster
so they would often say they would go i
mean how often did that happen when you
were growing up oh i got home okay i can
see the fry but you pull up to wendy's
and say that i'm missing the
cheeseburger
and the the few the ones you just got me
like a meal with no burger yeah one or
two times the one or two times somebody
said do you have a receipt i this is how
rare the receipts were i literally go
yeah i have a receipt from my drive
through me and they would be like all
right i guess you're right yes
so it worked it worked greatly
this is the story so one time the one
time
i go big i go for the big heist one day
okay i get greedy
what are you going for twice chicken i
get greedy right i go i go to mcdonald's
i get the big mac i go to burger king i
get the whopper i go to kfc i get
something um and i'm like you going are
you getting all these for free yeah i'm
getting one item in each place free and
then same scam and every place right oh
my god hold on wait dude bonus app next
time you're over we're getting in my car
you bring the handheld
we'll go to the ones around my house and
try to do this right now we'll see him
in action we'll try it i don't know if
you can do it anymore now though though
though because it's all about it it'll
be great if you fail it's great okay i
brace the whole show around that then i
go i
swear to god i go the one rule was never
go inside you have to do it with the
drive-through right yeah
because i can see it in your eyes yeah
yeah i get green besides different rules
i get greedy
like i did i pulled off three i'm going
for i'm going for wendy's too i'm
getting something from wendy's right
frosty so i go to wendy's the line is
around the block at the drive-through
i'm like i'm going inside
he's emboldened i go to the counter i
don't remember what i said they forgot
or whatever but let's just say fries or
whatever i don't remember
um
the lady goes oh do you ever see i go no
like who keeps their wendy's receipt
that's nuts and she's like yeah you're
you're right whatever she walks away
i see you're talking to the manager i'm
like oh [ __ ] it shouldn't be this
complicated
like i don't recognize you from an hour
ago so i'm standing there well it's the
drive it's so busy yeah you know like
they don't remember especially
lunchtime yeah so i'm standing there
it's she's taking forever i see the
manager talking i'm like [ __ ] i'm going
to get busted but like
you know so i start getting really
nervous
finally comes what they're going to tell
yeah she finally comes back she gives me
the fries
i go thanks a lot i take the fries and i
start
make a beeline for the door the manager
comes out
right and he goes let's go tape sir
sir i'm ignoring him i'm pretending i
can't hear him because i'm just like i'm
getting out of here which is the most
suspicious yeah yeah and he keeps doing
it sorry it's getting louder and louder
sir sir i finally get to the door it's i
can't i can't not
react
i turn around and go yeah and he goes
can you come here for a moment please
and i'm like you got to be kidding me
dude walk of shame from the door all the
way to the counter i get to the counter
he goes
his yeah i walk all the way to the
counter right he goes
have a free frosty for your trouble i'm
really sorry about that hands me a free
frosty i believe no
how you gripped baby wow that's how you
grip okay wow
did you turn around like yeah
wow even after the fast you would think
that with the fast walk and pretending
not to hear you yeah then he'd be like
oh wow i thought this was wow
shout out to that manager though he's
doing the right thing if it was a real
story if he's the biggest employee's ass
about we can't be having people you
can't be forgetting people's feelings
that's what they were talking about oh
wow okay so like so
like i never pay for parking unless
there's a game
no no no
so i don't ever pay for parking right
but if i get that's why i think this
battle is us versus customer service
that's the app
if i get a parking ticket even if it was
two minutes it pulls out
oh what
are you doing the arguments
even if even if i'm in two minutes right
i never get mad if i get a parking
ticket because i'm like i deserve it for
all the times that i didn't pay for
parking sure what i don't understand is
you both have stories of successful
scams especially ones that shouldn't
have worked right so when something
doesn't go your way or customer service
gets one over don't you think if you're
talking about being principled
don't you think you should be like you
know what the universe works
i need to get got sometimes because i've
like like the fact that you guys this is
my problem the fact that you guys go in
acting like you're owed something
when you've gotten one over on people so
many times well let me say you have to
allow the universe to to work you say my
my get god story
20 years ago i'm robin hood my get got
stories 20 years ago my recent stories
are no but don't you this is [ __ ] you
think on some level
that because you got that frosty
they're owed those headphones sure they
got them they won yeah but now without
being called a dildo in public so what
what's that gonna do with it you didn't
go in there like like big going like
yeah they got it they won you went no
but you're turning no i i will say this
it might def in my defense i do plenty
of times i'm in the mood of just
all right guys i guess i've never heard
that
i don't believe that
let's get a full episode of those
stories sam just remind me i gotta go
feed the meter but force derozan to do
the battle okay
right now
wow we really sidetracked all right babe
who wants to kick it off
i'll say that it's all fair game we
could double team this we already talked
the value of the cherry we already
talked about the value of the flavor of
the cherry and the flavor of a cherry
and a cola
cherry cola is the best dr pepper is a
poor competitor for cherry
it is a more of a cream-based soda it
can't hold a candle to it wait wait wait
wait wait okay okay uh and then the root
beer is like the dr pepper without the
edge yeah
first of all
you know but people earlier i don't
think you've ever had dr pepper i love
dr pepper nothing cream-based about it
yeah maybe you've had dr pepper and
cream soda which is a soda but if
anything root beer is more based aged
vanilla there is no cream i wouldn't
even agree with him in a dr pepper and
you tell me if it's a poor substitute
i'm gonna when you walk in you guys are
when you walk into any fast food
establishment you've already said that
you have i know you've walked in and you
look at that soda machine and you look
at what the options are how often do you
see
cherry coke i'll tell you where i always
see cherry never i'll tell you where i
see a cherry coke all the time where
every single movie theater i ever go to
because it is a treat for the treats
because it's a treat you know what treat
you know when you know when you have
treats
every so often you don't want to overdo
it with a treat yeah you want to have
one could you drink cherry coke every
day no absolutely i keep cases of it in
my apartment
i've never seen those kids i keep cases
of cherry coke zero in my apartment
cherry coke no you don't care i
absolutely do it's 12 secs not the case
sorry the 12th the the the the probably
last you two months because of how
seldom knows
i have one once a day once every other
day i also keep a regular coke zero on
deck
yeah no i like you know cherry coke is
too committed i will say one thing
though if and if i think you're our age
or maybe you're our age or a little
younger or less yeah yeah so do you
remember cameo the group came out of
this thing's word up absolutely oh i
know the song yeah word up yeah well
cherry coke got cameo to do uh an ad
campaign in the 80s that replaced the
words word up with cherry coke really
yeah they were like cherry coke
that nobody's gonna say about either of
our sodas i'm on the dr pepper wiki okay
dr pepper
was first of all born in waco and that's
always a location you want to hear
affiliated with one of your favorites
first of all you look at waco and the a
lot of people would say the government
was at fault for what happened at waco
not the p not the branch dividing early
advertisements for the song
early advertisements for the soft drink
made medical claims ooh what fun okay
okay let's talk about digestion restores
vim vigor and vitality where is that
let's talk about this
we need dr pepper to give it some type
of snake oil
why was what cherry coke what does that
come from coca-cola with cherries your
soda had cocaine in it
yeah so my soda is righteous
and yours is changed i will say
something about your soda you're just
you're just a barnacle on the ship that
is coke of course your w root is an
island of its own oh please a w root
is a w's flagship cola as well as
droopier in and of itself is an island
amongst other coalitions i mean i think
it's a double whammy if you want to a w
is the best of rupees
if you want to start throwing these
rocks coca-cola hit a grand slam
and then created a second flavor that
influenced every other soda company to
create the second flavor cherry 7up came
cherry sprite cherry pepsi they all came
here after sharing coca-cola credit for
the cherry did they also invent cherry
blow pops yeah no i'm giving them no the
body made the cherry
you think people were mixing their
coca-cola slurpee with the cherry flavor
before cherry coke came out everybody
does that now i went into the movie
theater and got an ic the other day i
said miss could you do me a favor could
you mix the coke and the chair she goes
like this of course i can because that's
what people do you know why
because it needs it yeah
pepper and something else you don't need
to because dr pepper is so delicious on
its own that's
the only thing strong enough here's our
strong dr pepper i like dr pepper i
appreciate that i like
coca-cola is the yankees you're bringing
a single a affiliate up with cherry
killings
yeah you're right about that you are
right you can't bring a single affiliate
to a professional jordan you're right
jordan and pippen all day long okay you
think cherry coke is pimping absolutely
nothing not even close
not leaving no here's something here's
something about that have you heard
pippin lately very bitter
and i left the tip and they said oh
scottie pippen was in here one time and
i left the tip and i go thank you so
much and i go did i beat scottie pippen
he goes yeah he doesn't tip and i go
what he goes i swear to god he goes his
nickname his nickname and all the
restaurants is no tip and pippin
can you believe that
i believe it's real
but i don't like because pippin doesn't
satisfy and neither does cherry coke
i had a limo driver once before it all
broke i swear to god he i go give her
driver to be famous he goes yeah tiger
woods they go what's he like he goes he
loves hookers
i was like get this out of here look
when you think about it turned out to be
true when you think about a cherry coke
let me tell you just like the coke's
already invented they go i guess we
could add something to it dr pepper
nobody even knows what it is yeah dr
pepper stands on its own and it's so
strong
you look down all the main sodas there's
pepsi coke
dr pepper also they tried to they tried
to clone them with mr pibb i think and
yeah
tried to come out with mr pizza oh
coke came out with mr pimps
if you're not into chipotle you're not
going to that's right dr robert came out
with cherry dr pepper since the 90s
you're not you're not advocating for
cherry you're ever dating your cherry
coke they didn't come out with cherry
coke dr pepper since the 1930s let me
say another one was sherry coke invented
hold on since the night i got 30. can i
get let me get
fact out since the 1930s a persistent
rumor about dr pepper is that we're
going to drink contains prune juice
that's how [ __ ] it tastes we're going on
rumors in here
that's rumors in here honestly i think i
don't think it's a good argument because
dr pepper tastes delicious if there's
prune juice in it god bless prunes
prune juice if you're gonna sit here and
say dr pepper's not delicious you might
as well leave your own restaurant i
think they have cherry vanilla cinnamon
i think i have
all the fans are chiming in supporting
sam saying of course there's 23 flavors
to dr pepper yeah they perfected it they
got all the flavors all together how can
we combine
cherry
the other flavors don't get to come into
the mix i can't argue coke with cherry
coke you can't argue dr pepper flavor no
no
this is what it takes to make a dr
pepper because that's how amazing dr
pepper is a lot of bones going through
cherry cream cherry coke came out in
1984
1919. congratulations
the greatest generation great yeah you
could you could drink it on your way to
get polio
what a twitter treaty
roy allen and frank wright that's the a
w pimp rate us to 23 flavors uh amaretto
almond blackberry black licorice caramel
oh carrots i mean it's just awful flavor
cherry
that's a man's wait i want to do i do
want to hear these start at the top all
right amaretto almond blackberry black
licorice caramel carrot clove cherry
cola ginger jupiter juniper
jupiter who doesn't love a splash of
jupiter you would have told me
before i we sat down today that dr
pepper had carrot and juniper in it no
one said she would have kicked you in
the balls go ahead
just get your point because you're gonna
get right back in here two ingredients
that stood out to me that you read in a
row were cherry cola no that's right
that's right
because what what cherry coke is it's
like dr pepper except with everything
good stripped from oh yeah you really
missed that amaretto
black licorice yeah
i gotta say it's just an acquired taste
i would like to have been there when
they were trying to trying out this
recipe yeah it seems like it seems they
put a lot of work under cannibals
i got news for you it was like
when someone said carrots i got carrots
it's not you two versus me you better
start defending your root beer let me
talk yeah the rupiah came first the
rupiah was so dominant it spawned the
chain of burger restaurants after it how
about that did coke do that is there a
coke restaurant no no there is no the a
by the way oh what the a w there's one
in every 53 states what are you talking
about aw restaurants are very popular in
montreal yes oh wow no no what i'm
saying is the rupiah was the first item
from them it was so popular it spawned
the restaurant when have you ever seen
an a w i've seen two of
alaska and canada okay
no i grew up
highland boulevard and jefferson avenue
in staten island right on the corner
it's now mike's diner rip a w root beer
we grew up on it the burgers were great
it was one of those ones where you also
drove up eight outside like sonic does
now but it was the ridge og and you'd
roll down the window we'd hit the button
it was a call button it was amazing it
was like you pushed it and then you get
it and then they bring it over and hang
it
off they had trays with these metal
clamps and they would you would roll
your window down like this and then they
would hang it off and the tray would be
outside and you know how fun that was
for a child not that has anything to do
with the rupee but the rupiah was the
icing on the cake that was the a w
experience by the way
what happens when you throw a scoop of
vanilla ice cream into a cherry coke oh
great it's not a rupee
fantastic
disgusting oh i was going to honestly
rupert floats are disgusting rubio float
might be the best dessert slash beverage
dessert ever made they could really use
shakes
you're out of your mind i think i might
go rupee a float when done right root
beer floats yeah no root beer floats are
incredible all right we got it we got to
go to the polls already wait
we're in the middle of a heated battle i
know remember when i see you saying
we're running out he knows he knows he's
lost he knows he's lost all right all
right all right yeah we got dr pepper is
a flavor explosion
i agree i'll tell
you go to mcdonald's you go to
mcdonald's that's the hierarchy of
everything sure
dr pepper is always available with coke
cherry coke never root beer nope
oh they they do they just do mugs strong
arguments do not have root
well guess what mug's not your root beer
i know it's not my review here's how i
think this is going to connect out i
think dr pepper is going to come in
first of course it is i think root beer
is going to come in second i think
you're coming in dl
and i think we're taking two l's this is
what i think is going to happen because
you can pick this something up
a substitute you know what it is
i'll talk as a person who is not a soda
drinker i rarely ever have soda rarely
the most i'll do is maybe once every
couple weeks i'll have a diet coke for
taste with my meal so as someone who's
not a soda drinker i actually really
plant my flag in the root beer because
it is a once in a while soda treat
beverage that i have that i think is
just it's just a special it's very
special beverage okay and that's your so
if you're using argument what's what's
interesting is good closing arguments
and my quote hold on good closing
arguments my closing argument is this
yeah coke is the greatest soda on earth
by by the population standards cherry
coke elevates it to the next level there
is nothing like the combination flavor
of cherry and cola which is why people
are mixing their cola slurpee and cola
and cherry syrupies together which is
why people love cherry coke which is why
everybody emulated having a cherry
flavored version of their soda after
cherry coke
all right no not pump no pep that's it
that's close i just wanna i just want to
just just like just you want to watch
the ingredients you respect it i want to
run out the ingredients in the doctor i
mean rupiah vanilla caramel wintergreen
black cherry bark licorice root
sarsaparilla root nutmeg my favorite of
all time
acacia i don't know what that is anise
molasses simmons sweet birch and honey
by the way that's not dr pepper still
wins with the ingredients
i don't know about that cherry in both
of yours carrot i get you had carrot and
juniper i'm coming to the chicken
i've heard cherry in both of yours and
then a bunch of old man ingredients done
black cherry bark pimp what you got in
yours you got maraschinos [ __ ] what do
we got pimp 11 000 votes 11 000 a lot of
votes yo pimple put this on the screen
for us we don't have a tv today
you ready okay start with the start with
the loser the loser yeah and then the
percentage 22
oh okay okay okay a w root beer yes oh
and you know why [ __ ] you
no
okay
can i tell you why that happened
can i tell you why that happened yeah
because
and i couldn't go against you because
joe was coming so hard at me yeah and i
needed your support yeah a w root beer
you're right is not a soda drinker soda
yeah and soda drinkers like soda yeah w
root beer is your dad's old man soda
it's not fun i stand by it aw i think
it's fun it's not fun at all it's it's
not it's fun for people who don't have
fun it's a rupe there's no other blank
blank float blank float well you said w
root beer is my favorite i said there's
a guy who doesn't drink soda there's a
guy doesn't have fun all right well i
have fun
second place pimp all right you ready 32
oh wait wait so 22 32 is 64 which means
someone won with 36. so 36 and 32 with
the top two 46 and 30s third 46 and 32.
oh that's a bad math okay okay okay so
number two here is cherry coke oh
yes at 32.
so 40 yes a very favorable nearly half
dominant dr pepper i know it's really dr
pepper it's amazing i do i really do
nice work i really do probably
that's something you know that's not
what the show is can i tell you guys
something
you came on and won do you know what he
did to us do you know how good it feels
to walk into the taste buds arena as as
a fan yes right because that's i'm here
as a fan
to walk into the taste buds arena a fan
and walk out undefeated yeah to say that
this is a i've had a lot of my dreams
come true in my life yeah man hosting a
radio show right working for wwe yes
but sitting on this couch with us
to say that today
is my ultimate dream come true will be a
complete understatement wow this is it
wow this is it for me i pray this is it
i'm happy you got the w yeah and i
appreciate both of you it makes me feel
good the winner
yes
which actually doesn't really thankfully
one of us didn't win yeah because well i
mean i would have liked to win but like
the 2l's kind of all right now he gets
the honor right yeah he gets the honor i
appreciate you affording me the
opportunity to win you guys are great
opponents you get to say the closing
line
i forgot to close it
i still love you guys i still love you
you love you babes i still love you
babes we love we love you too
[Laughter]
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to them